wow
what an event that php put on
what an event you know i was there last
year at the virtual event yep which was
30 people in a room
virtually you had pitbull
general mattis
uh trey gowdy
and it was really dope it was cool just
to see it function and it went off
without a hitch at a virtual event to
see an event put on at the mgm grand ten
thousand people in attendance nikki jm
performance sebastian maniscalco
all the leaders of the company people
talking and to see it go off without a
hitch live and in person
just respect everyone about tyson's
interview
everything tyson said what stuck with
you he said a lot of yeah mike tyson was
never heard before what are some of the
things that stuck uh he's like you know
i'm nine years old he says i don't know
how strong i was yeah i used to fight
like this he says people will come and
do stuff to me i'd go like this like i
didn't want to you know i don't want to
close my eyes and so i would knock
people out because that's when i
realized how strong i was
so he says one time i'm nine years old i
got fifty five hundred dollars cash in
my pocket and i'm going he just kind of
goes through that yeah
yeah i was fifty five hundred dollars in
my pocket how do you have 55 years of
robbing people
you're probably i'm straight up robbing
people at night nine years old nine
years old he says so eventually
everybody realized who i was he says
well i used to knock a lot of kids out
and then they would bring their daddies
and i would knock out their daddies yeah
yeah you guys would be the grown ass man
getting knocked out by the way who was
talking about was just i'll tell you he
was very honest yeah very very very
soft-spoken you know yeah very even
because you know there was a group of us
before
he was pretty happy though before when
we got there like in the romeo yeah he
smelled like he's uh
maybe it smoked something oh
it smelled like he just came out of his
pocket hotbox right yeah exactly it
smelled like he just came out of his
hotbox within five minutes i was with
him i was having chips
hey can we i
told caroline caroline we need some
chips we need some hey man but even like
when we were taking pictures you know
there was a few of us that met him
before
and took some pictures of them and he
was very gracious and shook our hands
and i even said hey mike like why don't
we stand like this hey man just peace
i'm not trying to i'm not trying to
fight you man right did you shake his
hands oh yeah he's got massive hands his
hands those hands felt like this made
sense yeah
this makes sense why this you know so
many people in the last few months yeah
because of you we've had the pleasure of
meeting some of the biggest strongest
athletes i've ever seen in my life mike
tyson yeah
bo jackson
gerard
uh bo jackson who's that guy's hands
were ridiculous
i think bo is in the league of his own i
don't know if i put anybody in most
league that guy's body is that guy just
made no sense what he looked mickey jam
crushed it by the way i mean i mean i
mean i mean i mean i mean he jam was i
thought he was gonna be good but i
didn't think he was gonna be great
because when i announced it you know
half the company's not latino half the
company is but the entire time people
stood up dancing for an hour straight
yeah sebastian manuscaka tells a joke
about matt zappala and it lights the
place up i messaged him afterwards he
says he says remind me to never say
anything to the guy in the green jacket
again exactly
sebastian maniscalco called out matt's
apollo nikki jam called out your friend
john mason made him dance yeah it was
just it was just an awesome event the
highlight was the ending though the the
the night the party you rented out
hakkasan
our friend michael francaise was there
flex wheeler was there showed up there
some friends were there showing up from
tigrin was popping bottles you gotta
give a shout him out to him by the way i
heard he got a great massage
yeah the massage is very good thank you
that's good stuff man i'm excited for
it's an inside joke but the world's
going to take in many different ways yes
just know that uh adam had a good time
as well yeah
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
[Music]